IT'S TIME TO PLAY
AMAZON BOOK FAIR: JUNIOR
EDITION.
(CHEERING, WHOOPING)
PARENTS, DO YOU WANT TO
TRAUMATIZE YOUR KIDS BUT DON'T
HAVE TIME TO DRESS LIKE A CLOWN
OR ENTER THEM IN BEAUTY PAGEANTS
OR TEACH THEM THE PIPE ORGAN?
WELL... WE FOUND A BUNCH OF
CHILDREN'S BOOKS ON AMAZON THAT
WILL MESS WITH YOUR LITTLE
ANGELS SO HARD THEY'RE SURE TO
GROW UP TO BE SLAM POETS OR
THOSE GUYS IN THE CIRCUS WHO
LIFT WEIGHTS BY THEIR PIERCINGS.
(LAUGHTER)
WE'RE GONNA SHOW YOU AN ACTUAL
CHILDREN'S BOOK, AND FOR 250
POINTS YOU HAVE TO TELL US ONE
OF THE CHAPTER TITLES, ALL
RIGHT?
FIRST ONE: I WISH DADDY DIDN'T
DRINK SO MUCH.
(LAUGHTER)
BY THE WAY, DADDY'S GOT A
BITCHIN' HOME THEATER, FROM THE
LOOKS OF IT.
(LAUGHTER)
I GUESS HE'S DOING SOMETHING
RIGHT.
>> DADDY'S WATCHING HIS STORIES!
GET OUT OF HERE!
(LIKE A CHILD): I WANT TO
ESCAPE.
>> HARDWICK: WHAT'S, UH...
ANDREW.
>> CHAPTER TWO: STICKS AND
STONES WILL ACTUALLY BREAK MY
LITTLE CHILDHOOD BONES.
(LAUGHTER)
>> HARDWICK: RIGHT.
POINTS.
(APPLAUSE)
>> HARDWICK: UH, BRENT.
>> (CHUCKLES)
DRIVING WITH DADDY IS SCARY,
EVEN WHEN HE CALLS IT "THE FUN
BUS."
>> HARDWICK: POINTS.
D'ELIA.
>> CHAPTER FIVE...
DADDY DRINKS SO MUCH BECAUSE
EVERYONE THINKS OUR LAST NAME IS
"VAGINA"-- LOOK.
>> YEAH.
>> THAT'S A GOOD FIND.
GOOD FIND, MAN.
>> NOW I WANT TO WIN-- THIS IS
WAR.
>> WHY IS SHE TAKING... WHY IS
SHE LEAVING WITH THE WHIP?
WHY'S SHE LEAVING THE WHIP?
>> HARDWICK: NO, NO, NO, SHE
JUST STOPPED HIM FROM HANGING
HIMSELF.
>> OH.
SMART, SMART.
>> HARDWICK: NEXT ONE: "THE LONG
JOURNEY OF MISTER POOP."
(BELL DINGS)
OR "EL GRAN VIAJE DEL SENOR
CACA."
CHRIS.
>> CHAPTER SEVEN: MR. POOP MAKES
A PIT STOP ON GUSTAV'S CHEST.
>> HARDWICK: YES, POINTS.
>> YEAH.
OH, YEAH.
>> OH, YEAH, OH, YEAH.
>> (GERMAN ACCENT) OH, THIS...
OH, THIS IS MUCH MORE THAN I
BARGAINED FOR.
>> HARDWICK (GERMAN ACCENT):
THANKFULLY... THANKFULLY, THIS
IS JUST A PIT STOP.
OH, NOW IT'S A REAL PIT STOP.
>> OH.
>> HARDWICK: UH...
>> NOW THAT'S SHIT FUCKING.
>> HARDWICK: YEAH.
>> BRINGING IT BACK!
>> BRINGING IT BACK AROUND.
>> HARDWICK: EVERYBODY...
>> ...PUT ON THE END.
>> HARDWICK: UH, BRENT.
>> UH-OH, MR. POOP SLIPPED OUT
AGAIN DURING DINNER.
>> HARDWICK: POINTS.
>> HEY, BY THE WAY, WHAT'S IN
ITS BAG?
LIKE, WHAT...
LIKE, WHAT IS... WHAT IS...
>> HARDWICK: OH, HE JUST THREW
SOME SHIT IN A BAG.
>> OH.
>> HARDWICK: UH, ANDREW.
>> UH, CHAPTER TEN: MR. PRUNE
AND HIS SPORTS CAR.
(IMITATES ENGINE)
>> HARDWICK: POINTS.
YUM.
>> LET'S GET OUT OF HERE, TURDS.
>> HARDWICK: YOU KNOW, THIS
ISN'T HARDCOVER, BUT I FOR
SURE... I PREFER SOFT COVER.
>> IT'S SO MUCH EASIER TO
DIGEST.
>> HARDWICK: EASIER TO DIGEST.
>> EASIER TO DIGEST.
>> HARDWICK: UH, NEXT ONE:
"THE POCKET BOOK OF BONERS".
(BELL DINGS)
"A... RIB-TICKLING OMNIBUS OF
SCHOOLBOY HOWLERS."
IT SAYS ON THE COVER.
DEFINITELY HARDCOVER.
UH... D'ELIA.
>> UH, "HOW COME MINE IS ONLY
THREE INCHES?"
FORWARD BY BRENT MORIN.
>> HARDWICK: AW, JEEZ.
>> OH.
>> HARDWICK: POINTS.
BRENT.
>> MY DICK IS NORMAL.
>> NORMALLY IN YOUR BOYFRIEND.
>> OKAY, OKAY.
WAIT...
>> WHOA, WHOA!
>> ANDREW, ANDREW.
>> WHOA!
>> ANDREW.
>> WHAT IS THAT?
QUIT IT!
WHAT IS THAT?
>> SEE?
>> GET OFF ME!
>> YOU HAVE THAT ON TAPE.
YOU HAVE THAT ON TAPE ON
MULTIPLE ANGLES, WITH MULTIPLE
ANGLES.
>> I DON'T CARE, FINE.
ANDREW AND I ARE TOGETHER.
AND HE KNOWS IT'S NOT THREE
INCHES.
>> HARDWICK: NEXT ONE, NEXT ONE:
"WHO CARES ABOUT ELDERLY
PEOPLE?"
(BELL DINGS)
"WHO CARES ABOUT ELDERLY
PEOPLE?"
UH, YEAH, CHRIS.
>> UH, CHAPTER ONE: EVERYBODY
CARES ABOUT ELDERLY PEOPLE.
CHAPTER TWO: PSYCH.
>> OH, THAT'S GOOD.
>> HARDWICK: ALL RIGHT, POINTS.
>> THAT'S GOOD.
>> HARDWICK: BRENT.
>> CHAPTER FOUR: GRANDPA'S DRUNK
AGAIN AT A FAMILY PARTY AND
TALKING ABOUT "THE JEWS AT THE
BANK."
>> HARDWICK: POINTS.
>> (GRUNTS)
>> HARDWICK: ANDREW.
>> CHAPTER ONE: LIFE.
J.K.-- DEATH.
>> HARDWICK: POINTS.
>> OH, IT'S GOOD.
>> HARDWICK: ALL RIGHT, LAST
ONE: "THE NIGHT DAD WENT TO
JAIL."
(BELL DINGS)
YES, CHRIS D'ELIA?
>> UH, CHAPTER FOUR: THE DAY YOU
LEARNED IT WAS EASIER TO JUST
TELL EVERYONE THAT DADDY DIED.
>> HARDWICK: POINTS.
>> THAT'S SO SAD.
>> HARDWICK: UH, BRENT.
>> CHAPTER SIX: DADDY'S NEW
RIPPED BODY AND TERRIBLE
TATTOOS.
>> HARDWICK: POINTS.
WHY DOES DADDY HAVE A TEARDROP
TATTOOED ON HIS FACE?
ANDREW.
>> CHAPTER FIVE: DADDY'S NEW
NAME IS "BRENDA".
>> HARDWICK: THAT'S WHAT HAPPENS
WHEN YOU GO JAIL.
POINTS.